the jogan experience it's interesting
that even today there's different
schools of thought like Sean Strickland
spars basically every day right whereas
Max holl he was at my gym for like three
years oh yeah was he he's a wild boy
yeah kind of had
to let him go oh did you the crazier
days yeah no he just kind of gets too
involved talking [__] about
people I can see that I I liked him in
the gym I liked him there he was a great
training partner you need at least one
guy yeah in your gym that that does that
and goes hard and makes everybody else
go hard yeah when they're going against
him so I liked it but other people
didn't yeah he just you know he just was
too disrespectful to teammates and stuff
I see and how's the young Sean
Strickland yeah no this is well no I I I
definitely see that and you know
I'm you always rooted for him when he
left you know it wasn't like I was like
I hope that guy you know no I I always
rooted for him I thought he had a ton of
potential I was yelling at him to go up
a away class CU he was always trying to
make
170 I'm like dude you need to go
185 you'd feel a lot better you you
compete just the you'd be fine competing
up there but everybody's always mentally
afraid to M be against the bigger guy
yeah he's a different fighter at 185
than he was at 170 at 170 you could see
he was compromised just like how I mean
he had have cut 25 pounds easy right
yeah no he's big he's way too big for
right 170 but when you saw his fight
with aagna were you shocked I I only saw
parts of that I didn't see the whole
thing I was somewhere else I didn't get
to see it It's [__] amazing yeah no I
I saw parts of it and yeah he he looked
great he looked [__] amazing the
crazy thing is how good his defense
I thought he would do well against him I
didn't think he'd do well just standing
up with him though I mean I thought on
your sign would get would outpoint him a
little
bit uh but I thought sea would take him
down and beat the [__] out of him if he
got on top well that's a lot of people
don't realize Shawn has a very good
ground game no very good yeah very good
he just doesn't use it very often he's
black belt Jiu-Jitsu good wrestling good
takedown defense you know he's solid
everywhere but he just loves to bang to
stand he doesn't have like huge power he
probably getting better at putting it in
better places
now but he wasn't like he's not a big
knockout guy but he definitely adds him
up and and really he's by far one of the
biggest pressure Fighters yeah that just
moves forward all the time well he's
also able to do that because of his
defense his defense is so underrated so
underrated and in that osag fight you
saw it so clearly yeah he's really hard
to hit so good at moving just out a
distance and then putting more pressure
back on you checking those those calf
kicks he's quick yeah I was I was super
impressed with that fight yeah and it's
even more impressive you know coming
back from an accident like he had too
mhm yeah he talks about it it's like my
quad's all [__] up on his right leg
like his one leg is just like the quad's
not even attached yeah which is
nuts yeah no it it it's but again it
just shows what the body can do if you
just let it yeah you know if you're just
mentally tough enough to push through
something well he changed his style a
little bit because of it you know he
stands different than most people stands
very straight up he always has yeah
always yeah when I'd Spar him I'd have
to I I quit aiming for his head I just
aim for his chest and it kind of stopped
him and then I could you know follow up
if I hit him in the chest I could follow
up and hit him again but he's hard to
hit yeah it's it's impressive and he's
the only guy doing that sort of Philly
shell style at a championship level it's
like very interesting seeing him out
there he looks different than everybody
else yeah he's he's quick that really
helps him not get hit also yeah but just
also I think when we're going back to
the different schools of thought in
terms of sparring he spars every day
it's most of his training is sparring
right so when you see him fight out Ofna
in the round the guy wasn't even
breathing heavy I mean he looked like
ready to go five more after that he he's
got a like just his natural ability is
his cardio among you know he knows how
to fight well too but naturally he just
has cardio for days well I I got to
think that has a lot to do with
constantly sparring so the sparring
thing is not there's not a lot of
tension very loose and very composed and
very efficient right